thank you very much get to the
announcements very quickly I do want to
recognize Paul Tash and thank him as a
dear friend for his service on the board
it's always sad when people leave the
board and Paul especially just fantastic
editor careful great sense of humor
really fun to be with important Daniel
Allen to be the new chair brings an
academic perspective into this and an
incredible reader and thinker and it's a
thrill to have her as the new chair and
of course sig Gissler who has I would
say broad youth and progressive thinking
to the Pulitzer is all through this and
you know there's nothing I think more
difficult than composing these juries
and bringing issues to the board and
trying to bring everything to this point
and sig has done that masterfully it
does seem to me having just one
editorial comment I suppose that it is
important so to mark this occasion when
two of the great publications in the
United States and in the world the post
and The Guardian us will receive the
Pulitzer Prize important to just observe
that we've lived since the 1970s with
Pentagon Papers and the kind of crazy
system that set up under the First
Amendment where the government is given
total impunity to operate in secrecy and
classify and over classify and there's
absolutely no right under the
Constitution on the part of the press or
anyone to insist that the government
turn over important documents or
information for the public interest
leakers leakers are completely exposed I
mean if they decide the public really
needs to know this
there I'm afraid extremely vulnerable to
prosecution and if they say it's
important for the public to have this
and the First Amendment should protect
that the answer thus far has been I'm
sorry but that's not the case it is
significant however that leakers are
rarely identified and when identified
rarely prosecuted but to be in a
situation where it's rare to be
prosecuted for something you've done is
itself fairly inhibiting and then the
press journalists editors can receive
this information take stolen property
know that it's been stolen and cannot be
stopped from publishing it and prior
restraints injunctions really not
allowed except under very very rare
circumstances on the other hand there's
this lacunae in the First Amendment that
says maybe they can be prosecuted after
the fact for publishing it and of course
it's not a very great freedom to be able
to publish something without an
injunction when you're going to end up
in an orange suit afterwards for having
published it so there's a ambiguity
there that has never been resolved and
of course it's customary for the US
government not to prosecute the press in
this absolutely unruly messy world which
has been described as kind of a war
between the press and the government it
seems to have worked fairly well
government has been able to operate and
and effectively and the public has been
able to get a lot of very important
information it's a big big open question
whether a that is a system that will
continue into the future have the facts
changed is that a different world Julian
Assange is not Ben Bradley and it's a
lot easier now to take government
information and the click of a button
and hand it over that's not to say it
should be different I think it shouldn't
but it's an open question that will have
to be
faced in this generation and of course
now it's an issue for the broader world
and it's just I think important today in
this somewhat historical moment that we
recognize a fairly recent system that
was constructed basically in the 19 late
1960s and 70s and has remained with us
to this day but is an open question for
the future and lastly let me just say
it's an enormous privilege for me
personally I think every member of the
board of the Pulitzer Prize feels this
way to participate in the process I've
never been part of any decision-making
that has more integrity to it than this
so all of you who have and will receive
awards today can take great pride in the
fact that this is a this is a process
worthy of the prize that you will get
shall we begin
we start with public service for a
distinguished example of meritorious
public service by a newspaper or news
site through the use of its journalistic
resources including the use of stories
editorials cartoons photographs graphics
videos databases multimedia or
interactive presentations or other
visual material a gold medal and of
course there are two awardees the first
the Guardian US for its revelation of
widespread secret surveillance by the
National Security Agency helping through
aggressive reporting to spark a debate
about the relationship between the
government and the public over issues of
security and privacy Janine Gibson and
Alan Russ Bridger please come forward to
accept the prize
the second prize goes to the Washington
Post for its revelation of widespread
secret surveillance by the National
Security Agency marked by authoritative
and insightful reports that help the
public understand how the disclosures
fit into the larger framework of
national security
Martin Barron and Bart Gellman please
come forward
breaking news for a distinguished
example of local reporting of breaking
news that as quickly as possible
captures events accurately as they occur
and as time passes illuminates provides
context and expands upon the initial
coverage
the Boston Globe staff for its
exhaustive and empathetic coverage of
the Boston Marathon bombings and the
ensuing manhunt that enveloped the city
using photography and a range of digital
tools to capture the full impact of the
tragedy Kristine chin one
Jennifer Peter and Mike Bello will
accept the prize today please come
forward
investigative reporting for a
distinguished example of investigative
reporting using any available
journalistic tool Chris Hamby of the
Center for Public Integrity Washington
DC for his reports on how some lawyers
and doctors rigged a system to deny
benefits the coal miners stricken with
black lung disease resulting in remedial
legislative efforts congratulations
Chris ambi
explanitory reporting for a
distinguished example of explanatory
reporting that illuminates a significant
and complex subject demonstrating
mastery of the subject lucid writing and
clear presentation using any available
journalistic tool
Eli Saslow of the Washington Post for
his unsettling and nuanced reporting on
the prevalence of food stamps in post
recession America forcing readers to
grapple with issues of poverty and
dependency congratulations Eli
local reporting for a distinguished
example of reporting on significant
issues of local concern demonstrating
originality and community expertise
using any available journalistic tool
will Hobson and Michael of Forza of the
Tampa Bay Times for their relentless
investigation into the squalid
conditions that marked housing for the
city's substantial homeless population
leading to swift reforms congratulations
will Hobson and Michael afford
national reporting for a distinguished
example of reporting on a national
national affairs using any available
journalistic tool David Phillips of the
Gazette Colorado Springs Colorado for
expanding the examination of how wounded
combat veterans are mistreated focusing
on loss of benefits for life after
discharged by the Army for minor
offenses stories augmented with digital
tools and stirring congressional action
congratulations David Phillips
International reporting for a
distinguished example of reporting on
international affairs using any
available journalistic tool jason's app
and andrew RC marshall of reuters for
their courageous reports on the violent
persecution of the roe hinga a muslim
minority in myanmar that in efforts to
flee the country often fall victim to
predatory human trafficking networks
congratulations Jason Zep and Andrew RC
Marshall
what is much
commentary for a distinguished
commentary using any available
journalistic tool Stephen Henderson of
the Detroit Free Press for his columns
on the financial crisis facing his
hometown written with passion and a
stirring sense of place sparing no one
in their critique congratulations
Stephen Anderson
distinguished criticism for
distinguished criticism using any
available journalistic tool Inga saffron
of the Philadelphia Inquirer for her
criticism of architecture that blends
expertise civic passion and sheer
readability into arguments that
consistently stimulate and surprise
congratulations
Inga saffron
editorial writing for distinguished
editorial writing the test of excellence
being clearness of style moral purpose
sound reasoning and power to influence
public opinion in what the writer
conceives to be the right direction
using any available journalistic tool
the editorial staff of The Oregonian
Portland for its lucid editorials that
explain the urgent but complex issue of
rising pension costs notably engaging
readers in driving home the link between
necessary solutions and their impact on
everyday lives
Eric Lukens Susan Nielsen Len Reed and
mark Hester will accept the prize
congratulations
editorial cartooning for a distinguished
cartoon or portfolio of cartoons
characterized by originality editorial
effectiveness quality of drawing and
pictorial effect published as a still
drawing animation or both
Kevin sires of the Charlotte Observer
for his thought-provoking cartoons drawn
with a sharp wit and bold artistic style
congratulations Kevin sires
breaking news photography for a
distinguished example of breaking news
photography in black and white her color
which may consist of a photograph or
photographs Tyler Hicks of the New York
Times for his compelling pictures that
showed skill and bravery in documenting
the unfolding terrorist attack at
Westgate Mall in Kenya congratulations
Tyler Hicks
feature photography for a distinguished
example of feature photography in black
and white or color which may consist of
a photograph or photographs Joss Hanner
of the New York Times for his moving
essay on a Boston Marathon bomb blast
victim who lost most of both legs and
now is painfully rebuilding his life
congratulations
Joss
the Pulitzer Prize in fiction for a
distinguished fiction by an American
author preferably dealing with American
life the Goldfinch by Donna Tartt a
beautifully written coming-of-age novel
with exquisitely drawn characters that
follows a grieving zbor grieving boys
entanglement with a small famous
painting that has eluded destruction a
book that stimulates the mind and
touches the heart congratulations Donna
Tartt
drama for a distinguished play by an
American author preferably original in
its source and dealing with American
life the flick by Annie Baker a
thoughtful drama with well-crafted
characters that focuses on three
employees of a massachusetts art house
movie theater rendering lives rarely
seen on the stage congratulations Annie
Baker
history for a distinguished and
appropriately documented book on the
history of the United States the
internal enemy slavery in war in
Virginia 1772 to 1832 by Alan Taylor a
meticulous and insightful account of why
runaway slaves in the colonial era were
drawn to the British side as potential
liberators congratulations Alan Taylor
biography for a distinguished and
appropriately documented biography or
autobiography by an American author
Margaret Fuller a new American Life by
Megan Marshall a richly research book
that tells the remarkable story of a
19th century author journalist critic
and pioneering advocate of women's
rights who died in a shipwreck
congratulations Megan Marshall
and poetry for a distinguished volume of
original verse by an American author
three sections by Vijay Sheshadri a
compelling collection of poems that
examine human consciousness from birth
to dementia in a voice that is by turns
witty and grave compassionate and
remorseless congratulations
Vijay Zeus Austria
and nonfiction for a distinguished and
appropriately documented book of
nonfiction by an American author that is
not eligible for consideration in any
other category Toms rivers river as a
story of science and salvation by Dan
Fagan a book that deftly combines
investigative reporting and historical
research to probe a new jersey seashores
towns cluster of childhood cancers
linked to water and air pollution
congratulations Dan Fagan
and the last prize is in music for
distinguished musical composition by an
American that has had its first
performance or recording in the United
States during the year become ocean by
John Luther Adams premiered on June 20th
2013 by the Seattle Symphony a haunting
orchestral work that suggests a
relentless tidal surge evoking thoughts
of melting polar ice and rising sea
levels congratulations John Luther Adams
so that's an honor to the Columbia
baseball team that has won the second
Ivy League championship in a row two
years in a row
thank you very much congratulations to
all of the winners
Thank You mr. president thank you I've
enjoyed teaming up with Lee and the
enterprise of sprinkling fairy dust on
all these winners it's been a great
privilege and a great honor and our
luncheon is now complete I urge you to
check our website in the days ahead
we'll have a slideshow and other
material from the luncheon and we now
have all the winners assembled out on
the front steps for kind of a graduation
picture thank you very much for coming
it's been a grand day